even when missiles and drones fired at
Ukraine are shot down there's no
escaping the possibility of death this
man now faces unspeakable tragedy under
the foil blanket lies the body of his
nine-year-old granddaughter according to
those at the scene it appears the three
victims including the child's mother and
another woman were hit by Falling debris
they were trying to get into a shelter
that was locked he showed the worst
people and the question they was before
and or after I can't say yes or no I can
give you clear answer for that in this
give the answer for that the mayor of
Kiev has ordered all public shelters be
checked to ensure they're accessible
while he was at the site
another siren every day this week the
capital has come under attack from
Russian airstrikes here in moldovan
luckily we don't hear Air Raid Sirens
or the sound of Russian Artillery just
20 kilometers from the Ukrainian border
and the war the European political
Community gathered for its second Summit
with security as the main topic Vladimir
zielinski called for Ukraine to be
admitted to Nato this year although
there's no sign that will happen
back in key families laid flowers and
toys where the nine-year-old was killed
June 1st is children's protection day in
Ukraine but parents confessed to feeling
powerless in the face of Relentless
missile and drone strikes
he sat in the corner of our Corridor he
cried saying that we're all going to die
I was terrified to hear this from him
since the full-scale invasion zielinski
says at least
484 children have been killed by Russian
aggression
Global News London